[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
MATTHEW VANDER
HEIDEN: So today I
want to continue our discussion
of amino acid metabolism.
And before we do
that, I just want
to come back for a few
minutes and revisit the urea
cycle and the Krebs
bicycle that we
discussed at the very
end of the last lecture.
I only want to do
that because it--
a lot going on with this cycle.
It can appear on the
surface to be confusing,
the molecules are hard to draw.
And so I just wanted
to draw it neatly here
for you one last time
and go through it again.
And so remember, if we start
from the amino acid arginine,
arginine can be converted into
the non-proteinogenic amino
acid ornithine, and in
the process, release urea.
That ornithine can then be
in the mitochondria converted
to citrulline, another
non-proteinogenic amino acid.
By picking up a
carbon and a nitrogen
from this molecule,
carbamoyl phosphate, which
is generated from
CO2/bicarbonate, as well
as ammonia and to
phosphorylations with ATP
to get carbamoyl
carbon phosphate,
that's added to ornithine
to get citrulline.
That citrulline and then combine
with the amino acid aspertate
to give this molecule,
argininosuccinate.
So arginine plus
a succinate on it.
And then loss of fumarate
leaves you with arginine.
That fumarate a can, of course,
go through the TCA cycle
to regenerate malate,
oxaloacetate, ultimately pick
up nitrogen on oxaloacetate
is that alpha-keto acid,
is transaminated to
aspertate, of course
getting that nitrogen
from glutamate
to alpha-ketoglutarate.
And glutamate, of course,
can get its nitrogen
either by transamination
with another amino acid
to an alpha-keto
acid, converting
alpha-ketoglutarate
to glutamate,
or glutamate can be generated
by this redox reaction
where it picks up on ammonia
via the enzyme glutamate
dehydrogenase.
So, you'll notice in this cycle
that ultimately the arginine,
the urea group-- what is
released as urea from arginine,
comes from the
carbamoyl phosphate.
So that's one of
these nitrogens that
was picked up in the synthesis
of carbamoyl phosphate.
And the other one
comes from aspertate,
which, of course,
can come from ammonia
via glutamate dehydrogenase
and transamination,
or from transamination
from nitrogen picked up
from any other amino acid to
ultimately end up on aspertate.
You'll notice that
there's redox balance
across this whole cycle.
And so there's a
NAD that's required
to reconvert the malate
to oxaloacetate to run
this half of the reaction.
But of course, if we
pick up an ammonia,
we also have a redox
reaction involved
in the glutamate
dehydrogenase reaction.
You'll see that ATP is also--
quite a bit of ATP is needed.
You need 2 ATP to generate
each carbamoyl phosphate,
as well as 2 ATP equivalents
to generate argininosuccinate,
because remember, if you go back
to your notes from last time,
you'll see that ATP to
AMP plus pyrophosphate
was part of the citrulline
and aspertate generating
argininosuccinate reaction.
And the last thing
is that CO2 is
required to run the urea cycle.
That's where the carbon
in urea comes from.
And that CO2 is, of
course, picked up
in the generation of
carbamoyl phosphate.
Now, I think sometimes we can
fall into the misconception
when we talk about these
that all cells generate urea.
That's not true.
So remember, different organisms
use different strategies
to excrete nitrogen. So
in us as humans, the liver
and the kidney would run the
recycle as I have drawn it here
as a way to ultimately
produce urea that
gets excreted in the blood--
I mean, sorry, in the
urine, whereas most tissues
in our body would
simply ship off
excess nitrogen from the
catabolism of amino acids
to the liver and the kidney
by generating either glutamate
or glutamine in the reactions
that we talked about last time,
and then those organs would
deal with-- use the urea cycle
to produce urea and get
rid of excess nitrogen.
But of course,
there's other animals
that will use other strategies
secreted as ammonia directly
or produce the purine uric
acid, which, of course,
we'll talk about next time,
how one can interconnect
all this amino acid nitrogen
metabolism with nucleic acid
nitrogen metabolism.
I just want to stress that
this glutamate dehydrogenase
reaction is a really
key reaction that
is necessary to get nitrogen
in and out of the system.
And once you get nitrogen
in and out of the system,
you can then use these
transamination reactions
to move nitrogens around
between amino acids
and alpha-keto acids using
pyridoxal phosphate as we
discussed last time.
This is shown up above also
as the bicycle reaction.
And again, just stresses
that you sort of
are running the urea cycle on
the right, this other TCA--
modified TCA cycle, if
you will, on the left,
and ultimately illustrates how
you pick up those nitrogens
and CO2 to generate urea.
But, of course, if
we're going to talk
about how you would make
amino acids, which is really
the topic of today,
how you break down
and synthesize the
carbon skeletons
of different amino acids,
well, obviously here's
arginine metabolism.
You can imagine
that you could use
the same reactions to produce
or break down arginine,
and that is what happens.
But I also want to talk about
the remaining amino acids.
In the remaining
amino acids, it's
really about how do we
deal with the carbon
skeleton, the alpha-keto acids.
And of course,
these are linked via
this pyridoxal phosphate-driven
transamination reaction.
Now, I don't have
time to in this course
to go through how each amino
acid carbon skeleton is
produced and broken down.
We'll discuss some major themes.
However, if I don't cover
your favorite amino acid,
because of course,
all people should
have a favorite amino acid,
you can look up the pathways
to make it or break
it down, and I
promise that if
you paid attention
through the whole class, you
have the skills to understand
that particular pathway even
if we don't study it in class.
So I want to remind
you that in general
for amino acid catabolism--
and this is in general.
Of course, there are exceptions.
Arginine would behave as I just
described for the urea cycle.
But for most amino acids, you
start with transamination.
So what does that give you?
That gives the nitrogen
to alpha-ketoglutarate
to generate glutamate.
And so that glutamate
can then be shipped off
to generate ammonia
if you're a fish,
generate urea if you're
a human, et cetera.
And what does that
leave you with?
That leaves you with a
alpha-keto acid related
to the amino acid that can
then be oxidized to CO2 using
various pathways-- burn it and
get energy, just like we've
described for carbohydrates
and fatty acids, or, of course,
in some cases produce glucose
or some other molecule that
can then be used to support
gluconeogenesis in the liver,
keep glucose high in our blood.
And so that's generally how
most amino acids are stabilized.
It's very clear how this works.
If we start with some of
the more obvious ones--
so we talked last time about
how alanine, the amino acid,
is related--
so transamination, get
the alpha-keto acid.
That alpha-keto acid
is pyruvate, aspertate.
Amino acid undergoes
transamination.
The alpha-keto acid
is oxaloacetate.
Glutamate undergoes
transamination.
alpha-keto acid is
alpha-ketoglutarate.
It's very clear how
all of these can end up
in the TCA cycle or
gluconeogenesis for The cell
to either oxidize for energy
or to produce something
like glucose that can
be used elsewhere.
Now of course, there's
other amino acids
out there that we've
already talked about.
So remember asparagine,
very similar to aspertate.
Glutamine similar to glutamate.
So those were the ammonia
group on the side chain.
We can simply remove those.
Should be clear how to
then get those into the TCA
cycle or gluconeogenesis.
A little bit of
metabolic trivia.
Humans, we actually
don't have an enzyme
to break down asparagine.
Other organisms do.
And then the other one that
we alluded to last time
was proline, which is cyclized
and oxidized glutamate.
And so I'll just
illustrate here quickly how
proline can be metabolized
just so you can see this.
So here's the
amino acid proline.
And so proline,
to show you, if we
do oxidation of this
carbon-nitrogen bond,
so that utilizes these
an electron acceptor.
That electron
acceptor happens to be
FAD being reduced to FADH2.
That generates this molecule.
We can then add water
across that double bond.
Now we can open up
the ring like this.
So just opened up the ring.
Now I'm going to oxidize
this aldehyde to the acid.
So if I do that, something
else has to be reduced.
That something else can
be NAD+ or NADP+ depending
on the enzyme.
There's enzymes that use
either NAD or NADP to make
NADPH or NADH respectively.
And then what I'm left with
is this amino acid glutamate.
And so that's how I turn
proline into glutamate.
Two additional oxidation
steps generating
FADH2 and NAD or NADPH.
And so that's how you
would derive energy
from the catabolism of proline,
by feeding it into glutamate,
which can then, of
course, be transaminated
to alpha-ketoglutarate,
and the rest of the carbon
enter the TCA cycle.
OK.
So that covers 1, 2,
3, 4, 5, 6 amino acids.
7 if you count arginine
that we talked about
with the urea cycle.
That leaves 13
additional amino acids.
Many of them are first
transaminated to the alpha-keto
acid, and then ultimately use--
the carbon skeleton
can be used to generate
another intermediate
that's either involved
in the TCA cycle or glycolysis.
And shown here on the
slide is basically
just a figure from
a textbook that
contains all of the various--
all of the 20 amino
acids from protein
and what they generate either
in the TCA cycle or up here.
So you can see here [INAUDIBLE]
oxaloacetate, fumarate
succinyl-CoA,
alpha-ketoglutarate, acetyl-CoA
pyruvate, acetyl acetate.
Which, of course,
as we saw last time,
can be used to
generate 2 acetyl-CoA
or be used to generate the
ketone body beta-hydroxy
butyrate.
Now, obviously if you can
generate any of these things,
we already know the pathways
about how you can oxidize them,
or, in some cases, how you
can turn them into glucose.
But now I want to
return to this idea
that we've come to a
bunch of different times
that really comes down to this
fact of what we talked about
with the TCA cycle, how the TCA
cycle can't net do anaplerosis
from two carbon units.
That is, you can't turn
acetyl-CoA or acetoacetate,
because that's just two
acetylcholine molecules,
into anything that
can generate glucose.
that We don't have
the glyoxylate cycle.
Organisms that have the
glyoxylate cycle can do this,
but we as humans cannot do that.
Now, many of our
amino acids can be
used to produce things like
fumarate, succinyl-CoA,
oxaloacetate.
All of that stuff can easily
be turned into glucose.
And so if we starve ourselves or
go on a low-carbohydrate diet,
well, what happens is, our liver
will break down amino acids
and use those amino
acids to make glucose,
but we can only make
glucose from amino acids
if those amino acids
are broken down
into something that's not
acetyl-CoA or acetoacetate
because we don't have
a glyoxylate cycle.
Just remember I mentioned
a couple lectures
ago when we talked about
the ketogenic diet,
a true ketogenic diet isn't
just low carbohydrates,
it's also low protein
because your liver will turn
that protein back into glucose.
And so if you really
want to be ketotic,
you have to limit
both glucose and--
both sugars and proteins,
because fat, of course,
will only be broken
into two carbon units,
and you can't turn
those into glucose,
so you instead turn
them into ketones.
Now, not all amino
acid skeletons,
though, can be used
to make something
that can generate glucose.
Some can only make stuff--
acetyl-CoA,
acetoacetate-- that can
be used to generate ketones.
And so this defines another
way to classify amino acids,
is so-called glucogenic amino
acids or ketogenic amino acids.
And this is a direct consequence
of what those amino acid carbon
skeletons are broken into.
And so a glucogenic
amino acid is really
any amino acid where
the product of breakdown
is greater than 2 carbons
that is not acetyl-CoA.
Whereas ketogenic amino
acid is an amino acid
where the product of
breakdown is acetyl-CoA.
And I should mention,
or acetoacetate,
because acetoacetate, as
we saw, is 2 acetyl-CoAs.
So acetyl-CoA, acetoacetate can
be turned into the ketone body
beta-hydroxybutyrate, an
alternative fuel for the brain.
If you break down an
amino acid and all you
get is acetyl-CoA
or acetoacetate,
you can't turn that carbon
skeleton back into glucose;
therefore, it's a
ketogenic amino acid.
All other amino acids that
generate oxaloacetate,
succinyl-CoA, whatever,
something greater
than 2 carbons, not
acetyl-CoA, it can then
be turned into glucose,
therefore, it's
a glucogenic amino acids.
Now if we come back
over here to our slide
and you look at the
various amino acids,
most of the amino acids are
turned into something that
can be turned into glucose.
And so most amino acids
are so-called glucogenic.
However, there's a few amino
acids that are ketogenic,
and there's some
amino acids that are
both glucogenic and ketogenic.
And so if you look here
through the slide, what you'll
find is that tyrosine and
isoleucine-- so there's
isoleucine, here's tyrosine.
So they're turned into
ketones, but they can also be--
here's tyrosine,
here's isoleucine--
can also be turned
into something
that can be used
to make glucose,
and so they're referred to as
both glucogenic and ketogenic.
Now, as I said before,
we don't have time
to go through how to break
down all of the amino acids,
but I will take you through
how you break down the three
branched chain amino acids.
And I will do that
because, first of all,
it will illustrate
that you already
know a lot about metabolism.
You'll see that how
these are broken down
is just variations on pathways
that we've already discussed.
And so it really
drives home the fact
that the complexity
of metabolism
is really just nature
repurposing relatively
few reactions over and
over and over again
in a way that ultimately builds
complexity and diversity,
but in the end,
is actually quite
consistent across
the whole thing.
And you'll also see examples
of how amino acid skeleton
breakdown can end up either
as glucogenic or ketogenic,
and that's because of the
various branched chain
amino acids.
So there's, of course, leucine,
valine, and isoleucine.
So those are the three
branched chain amino acids.
You'll see the
leucine is ketogenic,
valine is glucogenic, and
isoleucine, as I just said,
is both ketogenic
and glucogenic.
So three very amino acids.
In genetic terms,
very conservative
substitutions within a protein.
Very related structures.
However, the way they're broken
down, in the case of leucine,
generates only things
that are ketogenic;
valine generates things
that are glucogenic;
and isoleucine generates both.
And so we'll go through each of
these and see how that happens.
So let's start with leucine.
So leucine is a--
I said above is a
ketogenic amino acid.
And so leucine, like
many amino acids,
starts break down
by transamination.
So this transamination will,
of course, take the nitrogen
from leucine, an alpha-keto
acid, alpha-ketoglutarate,
generate glutamate, as well as
the alpha-keto acid of leucine,
which, just to remind
you leucine looks like,
looks like this.
So this is the side chain
over here of leucine.
Here's the alpha-keto
acid related to leucine.
If I take this
alpha-keto group, turn it
into an amino group,
that's leucine.
So this is the alpha-keto
acid related to leucine.
So the next step of
leucine breakdown
involves oxidative
decarboxylation
of this alpha-keto acid.
So if you remember, we've
seen this reaction before.
We did it in pyruvate to
generate acetaldehyde,
an ethanol metabolism.
We did it in--
well, we did alpha
decarboxylation there,
and then we did oxidative
alpha decarboxylation
when we turn pyruvate
into acetyl-CoA.
And we turned
alpha-ketoglutarate
into succinyl-CoA.
Well, that exact
reaction, which we
saw with pyruvate
decarboxylation,
as well as what we saw
with alpha-ketoglutarate
dehydrogenase generating
acetyl-CoA and succinyl-CoA
is what happens here for the
alpha-keto acids produced
from breakdown of leucine
and other branched chain
amino acids.
And so if you look
back in your notes,
we went through the
mechanism of this in detail.
Remember, this involved
edition of CoA, loss of CO2,
it's an oxidation reaction.
So remember, the electrons
needed to go somewhere,
and so they ended
up going to NADH.
So that's oxidized.
NAD+ is reduced to NADH.
And remember, this involved that
mini-electron transport chain
with FAD, lipoic acid, and TPP+.
And in the end, that
releases the CO2
and you end up with this
branched chain acyl-CoA.
So same reaction is PDH,
alpha-ketoglutarate,
dehydrogenase.
Just like those two
reactions, remember,
that had an E1, an
E2, and an E3 subunit.
So this actually uses
the exact same E2 and E3
subunit as those reactions.
The E1 subunit is,
of course, different
because it's unique to the
branched chain amino acids,
whereas in pyruvate
dehydrogenase,
to be unique to pyruvate
and alpha-ketoglutarate
dehydrogenase, you need
the alpha-ketoglutarate.
In this case, this enzyme is
called BCKDH for Branched Chain
Keto Acid Dehydrogenase,
and allows
the oxidative decarboxylation
to generate this branched chain
acyl-CoA.
Now this branched chain acyl-CoA
looks a lot like a fatty acid,
and in fact, it's
metabolized very much like we
would do fatty acid oxidation.
So what's the first step in
beta oxidation of fatty acids?
Well, we would introduce
a double bond here.
And so that's exactly
what happens next.
So this would be a
membrane-bound FAD
containing enzyme, part of
the electron transport chain.
Going to oxidize that
carbon-carbon bond.
There's that generate.
All right.
Now, if we are doing
fatty acid oxidation,
we would, of course, add
water across the bond.
We'll do that in a minute.
Before that happens,
the next step, though,
is that to facilitate
ultimately break down of this,
we're going to end up
adding our carboxyl group
to the end of the molecule.
So if we're going to add CO2
to the end of the molecule,
how would we do that?
Well, we've seen that reaction
many times before as well.
So if we're going
to add a CO2 group,
that's going to
come from biotin.
So the next enzyme would have
biotin in the active site that
can pick up a CO2.
How does it pick up the CO2?
Well, it picks up the CO2
via bicarbonate plus ATP,
and that's going to go to--
that's going to phosphorylate
the bicarbonate.
And then when we transfer that
phosphorylated bicarbonate
onto biotin, we'll release the
PI, then the CO2 from biotin
can be added to carboxylate.
That molecule, just
like we've saw before
with other
carboxylation reactions,
and that will generate
this intermediate.
This intermediate here.
OK.
So no new chemistry.
You've seen all this
many times before.
Now we're going
to continue with--
what we would do is if we
were breaking this down--
oxidizing it as a fatty acid.
And so now we're going to add
water across that double bond.
OK.
Now we added water
across that double bond.
And then now we're just going
to do this reaction, which
will generate from this side
of the molecule an acetyl-CoA.
And if you look on the other
side of the molecule, what we
are left with is acetoacetate.
Acetoacetate can be broken
down into two acetyl-CoAs.
If I break it in half, add
CoA to each one of them
by reactions I showed you
before as well, or, of course,
we can reduce this
ketone to the alcohol
and make the ketone body
beta-hydroxy butyrate.
You can look that up from
the end of the last lecture.
But in the end, this is
how one can break down
the leucine skeleton.
You get a acetyl-CoA
or acetoacetate.
Can't generate glucose from any
of those molecules as humans
because we don't have
a glyoxylate cycle.
Therefore, leucine is
a ketogenic amino acid.
All right.
Valine.
Let's look at valine.
So valine is glucogenic
despite the fact
that it's very
similar to leucine
and broken down in a way
that's very similar to leucine.
So, how do we break it down?
So first step, transamination.
Nitrogen from valine
to alpha-ketoglutarate
to generate glutamate, and
as well as the branched
chain alpha-keto acid
that's related to valine.
So that's the alpha-keto
acid related to valine.
One carbon shorter
than side chain, one
carbon shorter than leucine.
Just like we did
with leucine, we're
going to metabolize
the alpha-keto acid
with the branched chain
keto acid dehydrogenase.
Same reaction.
Oxidative decarboxylation here.
That releases CO2, adds CoA.
Reaction involves
also NAD+ to NADH.
Requires lipoic acid, TPP+, FAD,
just like we described before.
I'm not going to draw out
all the pieces of it again,
but we're going to end up with
the branched chain acyl-CoA.
Metabolize this
branched chain acyl-CoA
as if it's a fatty acid.
And so first step, oxidize
this carbon-carbon bond.
That electrons go
to FAD, make FADH2.
This product, add water
across that double bond.
Water across that double bond.
Next, if we oxidize
this alcohol twice--
so oxidize it once,
we'll get the aldehyde.
Oxidize it again, we can
get the carboxylic acid.
And so oxidizing twice means
NAD+ times 2 and NADH times 2.
And now that becomes the acid.
OK.
So same molecule, but now
this alcohol becomes an acid.
I drew it that way on purpose.
If you look back
in your notes, this
is methyl
methylmalonyl-CoA, which
we saw before in our discussion
of odd chain fatty acid
metabolism.
And you'll remember that there
was this B12-dependent reaction
where I can basically swap
the positions of this proton
and this thioester group here.
This is not aero-pushing.
This B12-dependent
reaction that I described
before where I can
rearrange methylmalonyl-CoA
to make this molecule,
which is succinyl-CoA.
Succinyl-CoA oxidized in
the TCA cycle, generate ATP,
but also can use it as
a substrate anaplerosis
for the TCA cycle, so it can
be used to generate glucose.
And so that's why valine
is a glucogenic amino acid.
All right.
Last branched chain
amino acid is isoleucine.
So isoleucine is both
ketogenic and glucogenic.
So let's see how that happens.
So if we start with
isoleucine, first we
undergo transformation.
alpha-ketoglutarate
to glutamate,
and you get the branched
chain alpha-keto acid.
So that's isoleucine as an
alpha-keto acid rather than
an amino acid.
Next step, do the
alpha decarboxylation
with branched keto
acid dehydrogenase.
That removes that CO2, oxidizes
that carbon to the acid,
and we end up with this
branched chain acyl-CoA.
Same first steps
as we saw before.
Metabolize that as
if it's a fatty acid.
So oxidize that
carbon-carbon bond.
Add water across
the double bond.
OK.
Get this intermediate.
Now oxidize this
alcohol to the ketone.
Electrons go to an NAD+,
which is reduced to NADH.
Now we can use CoA to take off
this end of the molecule here,
which is acetyl-CoA,
hence ketogenic.
The remainder of the molecule
is this three-carbon acyl-CoA.
We saw this from odd chain
fatty acid metabolism.
This is propionyl-CoA.
Remember, to deal with
that, we can add CO2.
So that, of course,
requires biotin, and ATP.
So remember, we had
CO2 to this molecule.
That gives us methyl--
not going to draw it all
out for the sake of time,
but that gives us
methylmalonyl-CoA.
Methylmalonyl-CoA
shown up there,
so it's adding CO2
to this molecule.
And then we can do the
vitamin B12 rearrangement
to get succinyl-CoA.
And so that can be
turned into glucose.
And so it generates an
acetyl-CoA and a succinyl-CoA,
isoleucine is both
glucogenic and ketogenic.
And so a little tedious to go
through how you break down all
three of those branched
chain amino acids,
but it really illustrates
that it's just
variations on the same
chemistry that we've
seen before with fatty
acid metabolism, TCA cycle
reactions, that ultimately
generate intermediates that
can be fed into the TCA cycle,
oxidized further to CO2,
generate ATP, generate NADH,
electron transport chain,
oxidative phosphorylation,
supply the cell with energy
to do various kinds of work.
Or can be turned into a
ketone if you're a human
and you start with acetyl--
and what you get is
acetyl-CoA or acetoacetate.
Or even into
glucose if you start
with something like
succinyl-CoA that
can be turned back into
glucose by the liver,
defining the difference
between the glucogenic
and the ketogenic amino acids.
All right.
Now going through branched
chain amino acid metabolism
also allows transition
into a discussion
of another topic which
are the so-called inborn
errors of metabolism.
So what's an inborn
error of metabolism?
Well, sometimes
individuals are born
that have deficiencies
in enzymes
that are necessary to carry out
some function of metabolism.
Some aspect of the biochemistry
we've been learning about.
Now you can imagine that some
of these genetic deficiencies,
if it's somewhere smack in
the middle of central carbon
metabolism and you
can't generate energy,
it's not going to be
compatible with life.
But it turns out
that some of them
are quite compatible with
life, like deficiency
in branched chain keto
acid dehydrogenase.
So BCKDH deficiency is something
that children are sometimes
born with, and this deficiency
results in a disorder
called maple syrup
urine disease.
So it's called maple
syrup urine disease
because the unit smells
like maple syrup,
but effectively what this is
is this is a disorder where
there's a deficiency in
the activity of branched
chain keto acid dehydrogenase.
That means the cells
can't break down
branched chain amino acids.
They end up generating some
otherwise side toxic product.
Some of it ends up in the
urine, smells like maple syrup.
But it also can result
in damage to the CNS
and problems with thinking,
mental retardation, et cetera.
And so it can be quite
devastating to have
loss of this enzyme, which
prevents you from breaking down
branched chain amino acids,
a so-called inborn error
of metabolism.
Now this is a
relatively rare disease.
All of these are.
But if you go to
medical school, these
are questions because
they lend themselves
to questions that often show
up on various board-type exams.
And so it's good to
know that deficiencies
of some of these enzymes
can result in diseases.
So maple syrup urine disease
caused by an inability
to break down branched chain
amino acids because you're
deficient in the enzyme
branched chain amino acid--
or branched keto
acid dehydrogenase,
which catalyzes the stuff
I showed you up there
in the breakdown of all three
branched chain amino acids.
By no means is
this the only one.
Often these are associated
with amino acid breakdown.
And so two of the
other more common--
all of these are very rare,
but relatively more common ones
is a disease called
alkaptonuria.
So what's alkaptonuria?
Well, that's missing an enzyme--
so enzyme deficiency in
tryptophan metabolism.
And another one is
fennel phenylketonuria,
which is an enzyme deficiency
in phenylalanine metabolism.
Branched chain amino acids are
very common, but tryptophan,
phenylalanine, two of the
more rare amino acids,
it turns out these are two
of the amino acid breakdown
deficiencies that have
less severe phenotypes,
and so they're somewhat--
more people walking around
with those conditions.
If any of you have had
children or someday
when you have children,
what will happen
is that you will notice
that when babies are born,
one of the first things
that's done with infants
is they have a
blood test sent out.
They do a little heel
stick, collect some blood,
and send it to the
state lab where
they test for various
inborn errors of metabolism.
What they're looking for is
things like phenylketonuria,
maple syrup urine
disease, et cetera.
Why do they want to
find these things?
Well, it's because if you
have too much of the product,
too much phenylalanine, too much
tryptophan, too much branched
chain amino acid, and you
can't break them down,
it's not the lack of the
ability to break them down
that's necessarily the problem.
The problem is is that the
inability to break them down
leads to overwhelming
a system building up
of toxic intermediates
that damage the brain.
And so by doing these
newborn screening panels,
it's greatly enhanced the
management of these things,
because often you can
control the symptoms
by dietary intervention.
Simply limiting
the phenylalanine
or the branched chain amino
acid or the tryptophan intake
in the diet is a treatment
for these diseases,
and so therefore, if you
know about them early,
limiting exposure
to those things
limits the exposure to the
toxic breakdown products that
can't be metabolized because of
the deficiency, and therefore,
limits the effects on the brain.
If you drink diet soda and you
look at the side of your diet
soda can, what's written on the
side of it is phenylketonurics,
contains phenylalanine.
Why is that written there?
Well, because if you happen
to be a phenylketonuric,
you shouldn't drink diet soda.
Why?
Because the artificial
sweetener in there contains
phenylalanine, and so
this would give you
a big dose of phenylalanine,
and if you can't break down
phenylalanine, that's a problem.
So it's a warning to the
people in the population who
happen to have phenylketonuria
not to drink diet soda.
All right.
Now, I want to say
a few other things
about amino acid metabolism,
only because these things will
come up for you as you
go through other aspects
of biology.
And that is that amino acids are
very versatile starting points
to build all kinds of
hormones and neurotransmitters
and bioactive molecules.
So I know some people--
some of the MIT students
in the class are course 9.
That's the brain and
cognitive science.
Classes you take,
you'll learn a lot
about different
neurotransmitters.
Well, one of the canonical
neurotransmitters
is an amino acid itself.
It's the amino acid glutamate.
So obviously that's important
for the brain to work.
But what are the other
neurotransmitters?
Well, there's things
like dopamine,
epinephrine, norepinephrine.
These are all
bioactive molecules,
have to come from somewhere.
Well, it turns out all
of these ultimately come
from the metabolism of tyrosine,
which, of course, can also
come from the metabolism
of phenylalanine.
And so don't have
time to go into it,
but you can look up the
pathways to generate
these various
neurotransmitters from tyrosine
if you're interested.
What's the other big
neurotransmitter?
Well, it's acetylcholine.
What's acetylcholine?
Well, let's break it down.
Well, it's an acetyl group,
so that comes from acetyl-CoA.
And choline-- and
what's choline?
Well, choline comes from,
ultimately as I showed you--
alluded to before,
ethanolamine, and ethanolamine
comes from serine.
We'll come back to this later.
And so serine metabolism,
as well acetyl-CoA,
is how you get acetylcholine.
It's also choline the
phospholipids and ethanolamine
for the phospholipids.
If you're not into the
brain but into other aspects
pathophysiology--
so thyroid hormone,
very common thing
that many people
need replacement of, very
important to manage physiology
in our body.
Thyroid hormone also
comes from thyroxine.
Melanin, the pigment that makes
our skin different shades,
melanin, the skin
pigment, it is basically
produced from dopamine--
or actually, a
dopamine metabolite.
So dopamine precursor.
Which comes from
tyrosine as well.
And so if you're
interested in any
of these particular
molecules, of course,
you can look up in the book and
you'll see how they're made,
and I promise, you have the
ability to understand it,
it's repurposing some reactions
that we've already seen.
There's some unique
ones in there
like melanin synthesis
is actually parts
of it are non-enzymatic, even.
But this-- I like to mention
this because obviously we
don't have time to
study and discuss
the entire complexity
of the metabolic map,
but really, you understand
the basics, the central parts
of it, and it's the same
reactions repurposed out
in different
directions that allows
this complexity and this
diversity of metabolism,
making all of these
different biomolecules that
are necessary for the cells
to do things, and, of course,
you can go look these up
if you're interested in any
of them specifically.
And regardless, you should
have some appreciation
of how these things
all interconnect
with the other pathways
that we've talked about.
All right.
So now I want to turn
to amino acid synthesis
and say a few words about
how amino acids are built.
So of course, we've covered
some of these already,
and as a very general
statement, many of them
are made by transamination.
So first you build
the alpha-keto acid,
and then you transaminate that
alpha-keto acid from glutamate
to generate the amino acid.
Now of course, the pathways
that you use to make amino acids
are not the same as
the pathways that you
use to break down amino acids.
So again, if you paid attention
for the entire course,
it should be clear for both
thermodynamic energetic reasons
that you can't have the same
pathways to build and break
stuff down because all pathways
delta G has to be less than 0.
So we saw this with
glucose and fatty acids.
We can repurpose-- some
steps can be the same,
but the ones that allow
the energetic driving have
to be different because you
have to couple one direction
to energy consumption
and the other one
could be spontaneous
if it releases energy,
and you have to
have pathways that
can work in either direction.
But, in general, if you can
build an alpha-keto acid
like oxaloacetic acid
or alpha-ketoglutarate
or pyruvate, well,
obviously we can
transaminate all of these
things to get the amino acid.
So alpha-ketoglutarate
to glutamate
can also be from
glutamate dehydrogenase.
That's how you can get new
nitrogen into the system.
And that way we can
generate aspartame
glutamate and alanine, and
aspertate into asparagine,
asparagine by adding
the ammonia to it.
That would be a very
similar reaction
to glutamate into glutamine.
That's glutamate synthase,
asparagine synthase.
Same mechanism describe
glutamate synthase last time
to make glutamine.
And of course, proline,
as I showed you earlier,
is cyclized, and in
this case, oxidized--
or sorry, cyclized
then reduced glutamate.
And then-- so that's
six of the amino acids.
We covered arginine
earlier, that seven.
And so 13 other amino acids.
Here's another figure
from a book just showing
the starting material to make
all of the various amino acids.
Obviously we know how
to make oxaloacetate,
phosphoenolpyruvate, erythrose
4-phosphate, pyruvate,
ribose 5-phosphate,
3-phosphoglycerate,
and alpha-ketoglutarate.
And so generation of
those by the pathways
we've already talked about
then allows those molecules
to be shunted into
pathways to generate
all of the various amino acids.
Now I want to
reiterate, humans, we
can't make all 20 amino acids.
Animals can't do that.
Many organisms, of course, can.
We lost the ability to make
nine of our amino acids,
and in fact, if you count the
two conditional ones, really
11 of amino acids, even though
we can turn phenylalanine
into tyrosine, we still need
a source of phenylalanine
to do so.
And so each of these nine or 11,
depending on how you count it,
essential amino acids
must be eaten in the diet.
So there are obviously
pathways to do them,
we just don't have the
enzymes in humans to do it.
And then the other
ones we do retain.
You can obviously
look up the pathway
that's used by whatever
organism to make
your favorite amino acid.
Today what I want to discuss
is how we will make--
today I want to discuss how we
will make serine and glycine,
because it turns out,
serine and s metabolism
play a key role
in other pathways,
including nucleotide
synthesis which we
will cover in the next lecture.
Serine glycine
metabolism also is a way
to make one carbon units that
are more reduced than CO2.
And these will be critical for
one-carbon transfer reactions
that you'll encounter throughout
other aspects of biology.
So, serine and glycine,
very important amino acids.
And so just to be
clear about this,
so it turns out
serine-glycine metabolism,
important for nucleotides
among carbon units,
we'll see that a lot.
But serine and glycine also
used to make phospholipid head
groups.
Nucleotides, one-carbon units
we're going to talk about.
I want you to
appreciate, you also
need serine to make
phospholipid head groups.
So what do I mean by that?
Well, of course, there's
phosphatidylserine.
Obviously that's serine is the
head group, and so serine--
the amino acid is
required for that.
But also used to
generate ethanolamine.
So what is ethanolamine?
Well again, just to
remind you of this,
so here is the
amino acid serine.
So, to generate
ethanolamine, it's
decarbonization of
serine to do that.
So loss of this CO2.
This is a reaction I don't
have time to go into,
you can look it up.
It is another repurposing
of pyridoxal phosphate.
And that generates
this molecule,
which is ethanolamine.
That ends up head group on
phosphatidylethanolamine.
And if I want to
turn it into choline,
either for acetylcholine
as a neurotransmitter
or for phosphatidylcholine
as a head group,
it's basically adding
3 methyl groups
onto this nitrogen
of ethanolamine.
And so those three
methyl groups,
that's a carbon that's
more reduced than CO2.
That's a so-called
one carbon unit.
It turns out, as you'll see,
those also come from serine.
Last thing is serine
is necessary to make
head groups for a class of
lipids called sphingolipids.
There's a-- sphingosine is
another amino alcohol that
is generated from serine
and ends up being the head
group for sphingolipids.
Especially if you're
interested in the immune system
of the brain, these end up
being important molecules.
And so you can
look up how they're
related to serine, but just
appreciate that for now
that they--
another important
downstream thing that's
generated from
serine metabolism.
Also illustrating
how amino acids
can be very
important to generate
lots of other biomolecules.
OK.
So, how do we make serine?
Well, if we go over
here, you'll see
that serine is downstream
of 3-phosphoglycerate
from glycolysis.
So what's 3-phosphoglycerate?
OK, here's 3-phosphoglycerate
from glycolysis, or the product
of rubisco if you like.
So photosynthesis.
So there's 3-phosphoglycerate.
So if I oxidize this
alcohol to ketone,
electrons have to go somewhere.
NAD+ reduced to NADH, I
get this intermediate.
It's phosphohydroxypyruvate So
pyruvate with a phospho on it,
hydroxypyruvate.
This molecule can undergo
a transamination reaction.
So pick up nitrogen
from glutamate,
make the alpha-keto acid.
Take this alpha-keto acid
and generate phosphoserine.
The amino acid that's
phosphorylated, phosphoserine.
And then all I need to
do is dephosphorylate it,
and I end up with the
amino acid serine.
Cool.
All right.
To make glycine from serine--
so remember, glycine is one
basically the amino acid
with no side chain on it.
So I need to remove this
carbon and the alcohol.
So I'll just redraw
serine this way.
So that's redrawing serine.
Need to lose that
group to get glycine.
This is helped along
by pyridoxal phosphate.
So a reminder, this is
pyridoxal phosphate.
OK.
So this is exactly what we
drew, is the first steps
in transamination.
Except if instead of
basically going like this,
I do this to break this
carbon-carbon bond,
what do I get?
Well, I release a
one-carbon unit.
In this case, it's
the one-carbon unit
as formaldehyde.
The one-carbon
aldehyde, formaldehyde.
And generate this intermediate.
And it's just exactly what we
showed before for resolving
the transamination.
And I am left with glycine, as
well as I regenerated pyridoxal
phosphate for the next
catalytic cycle of the enzyme.
And so illustrates
the flexibility
of pyridoxal phosphate.
In this case, helping
convert serine into glycine
and a one-carbon unit
shown here as formaldehyde.
Now the enzyme that
carries out this reaction
is an enzyme called
SHMT, which stands
for serine
hydroxymethyltransferase.
Serine hydroxymethyltransferase.
And it actually doesn't release
the formaldehyde directly.
Instead, it transfers
that formaldehyde
to an important one-carbon donor
for many one-carbon reactions
that is called folate
species or folic acid.
So remember, if we transferred
CO2 in a carboxylation
reaction, we use
a cofactor biotin.
Biotin's useful to transfer CO2.
But if we're going to do
something like transfer
the methyl groups shown up there
for choline synthesis, that's
transferring carbon that's
more reduced than CO2,
and you don't use
biotin for that.
Instead, you use
a cofactor called
folate that's derived from
the vitamin folic acid.
So folic acid, very
important vitamin.
It's the primary thing that's
included in prenatal vitamins.
Why is that?
Because deficiency in folic
acid was shown a while back
to cause neural tube defects--
so developmental defects where
the neural tube does not close.
This leads to things
like spina bifida.
One of the real successes of
public health intervention
was the recognition of this
and fortifying various cereals
with folic acid.
And doing so has greatly
reduced the incidence
of these birth defects
involving folate deficiency.
Folate deficiency's also
a common cause of anemia.
And so folic acid is a
vitamin that lots of people
take for that reason.
And in fact, folic acid, also
very important in the history
of cancer treatment.
And if you want to
learn more about that,
take 745, which is
offered in the fall.
All right.
So, folic acid is
a complex molecule
that is converted in cells to
a molecule called THF, which
stands for tetrahydrofolate.
So I'll draw out folic acid
for you and tetrahydrofolate.
OK.
So, this here is folic acid.
The folic acid molecule
is tetrahydrofolate.
It has a peptide bond here
to a glutamate molecule,
and it's actually a
polyglutamate tail that
is there to trap it in cells.
It's this central part
of the molecule here
that actually carries
the one-carbon unit.
And so the way that the
nitrogens are numbered,
this is nitrogen-5.
This is nitrogen-10.
That will be
important in a minute.
But it's really this
sort of central part here
of the molecule that I will
draw over and over again
as the one-carbon
unit-carrying species.
To show how this
works, it's easier
if I start off by showing
how it can pick up a more
oxidized one-carbon unit.
So the one-carbon carboxylic
acid is this, that's formate.
And so if I phosphorylate
formic acid,
this formic acid can then
be picked up by the--
so here's that carrying
part of the one-carbon--
the box part of
tetrahydrofolate.
And so this can pick up
formic acid like this.
OK.
So that gives us
this molecule, which
is called
N10-formyltetrahydrofolate,
THF.
I can create a ring
out of this molecule.
This.
OK.
And if I remove water from this
ring, we draw it like this.
OK.
This is called
N5,N10-methenyl THF.
And if I reduce that
molecule, it's NADPH.
So hydride ion.
OK.
Then I end up with
this molecule,
which is N5,N10-methylene THF.
And if I further
reduce this molecule,
then I end up with
this molecule,
which is N5-methyl THF.
Appears incredibly complex
what's going on here,
but I went through this, because
what I want you to realize
is that each of these
species are simply
tetrahydrofolate carrying
a one-carbon unit
in a different oxidation state.
So this N10 formyl THF
is carrying formic acid,
the one-carbon acid.
I can reduce it to
N5,N10-methylene THF.
That's carrying the one-carbon
aldehyde, formaldehyde.
Or I could reduce it further.
This is carrying the one-carbon
methyl group as N5-methyl THF.
And it turns out that this
allows a lot of flexibility
in carrying out
one-carbon reactions.
Here is a same thing
written from a textbook.
The direction-- the order is
shown a little bit differently,
the molecules are rotated.
And it includes a
couple other species
that are added in for
histodine metabolism.
But if you look at
this, you'll see
it's exactly what
I just drawn where
you get these key species.
Where N5-methyl
THF is effectively
carrying a methyl group.
So a one-carbon methyl donor.
N5,N10-methylene THF is
carrying the formaldehyde.
And N10-formyl THF is
carrying the formate group
to donate as a one-carbon unit.
This will be the donor,
ultimately, for things
like choline synthesis.
Formaldehyde-- and
N5,N10-methylene and formyl THF
will be important in nucleic
acid synthesis and we'll see
that next time.
And so now if we go back
to our SHMT reaction,
I can show you how these
things really work.
And so here's a THF molecule.
And so here is the intermediate
in serine-glycine conversion
found to pyridoxal
phosphate, et cetera.
And that will release
glycine and eventually PLP.
So glycine and PLP can
be generated from that.
And what ends up here
on the folate is--
which is N5,N10-methylene THF.
And if I take this
and I oxidize it,
I can take the
aldehyde to the acid.
So oxidation.
NAD+ is reduced to NADH.
Now I get an N10-formyl THF.
And if instead I reduce it,
so electrons from NADPH go
to NADP+.
So NADPH gets oxidized,
electrons go there.
And then I get an N5-methyl THF.
This gives me a donor
of methyl groups.
of formyl groups.
All right.
Very last thing I want
to talk about today
is we'll talk a lot about how
we use the more oxidized species
next time to
generate nucleotides,
but I want to say a few
words about how these methyl
groups are used to be
involved in methylation
reactions, things like
choline synthesis shown up
there, but also not
just choline synthesis.
Also can be used for reactions
involved in, say, epigenetics.
And so for those of
you who will never
think about biochemistry
again after taking
this class but we'll take--
think about genetics,
you'll certainly
know the gene
expression is controlled
by methylation of DNA and
histones and things like that.
Those methyl groups have
to come from somewhere,
and they come ultimately from
these methylation reactions,
the serine there.
Now I don't have time
to go through all
of one-carbon metabolism.
This is very complex.
But it turns out
the one-carbon donor
for most methylation
reactions isn't N5-methyl THF,
even though that's where
the methyl group comes from.
It's actually this molecule.
So this here is the
amino acid methionine.
And if I put it here onto an
adenine, what I end up with
is this molecule called
S-adenosylmethionine or SAM.
This methyl group on
SAM is very labile.
And so it is the
universal methyl donor
to be used in
methylation reactions,
choline synthesis, epigenetic
methylation of DNA or histones,
whatever.
And if you transfer
that methyl group off,
you're left with this
non-proteinogenic amino acid
that's called homocysteine.
And that homocysteine
is here onto an adenine
to make S-adenosylhomocysteine,
which is abbreviated as SAH.
SAH picks up-- needs
to regenerate SAM.
Methyl group has to
come from somewhere.
This comes from N5-methyl THF.
Of course, generates THF.
And then THF can pick up
another methyl group, ultimately
from serine-to-glycine
conversion and reduction
with NADH to make N5-methyl THF.
I show here on the
slide, here's just
a picture of
one-carbon metabolism
that I took from
a review article.
And so here's SAM metabolism.
Lots and lots of
complicated reactions
that are linked to cystine
metabolism and polyamine
metabolism.
Obviously don't have
time to get into this,
but I want you to appreciate
that this happens, where
SAM and SAH come from,
how they're involved
in one-carbon metabolism,
because this will come up
again in your future
endeavors if you do something
with biology.
All right.
Final topic next time is
nucleic acid metabolism,
and then we will
have covered all
of the basics of metabolism.
Thanks.